[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the long-awaited full review of the
brand new htc one m8
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so really when you're talking about the
one m8 from htc last year's m7 was a
killer in terms of design and when you
compare it to its feature flagship rival
from samsung the galaxy s5 they actually
have basically identical internal specs
which means the design and the physical
way it feels in the hand is more
important than ever and there literally
couldn't be a bigger difference between
the two so i'll be comparing them in a
separate video later but if you watch
any of the promo material for the m8
you'll notice it's all about that design
and the build quality and the material
choices and that's really where this
phone excels that's its highlight and
it's the same material we have of the
old htc one but it's obviously a little
bit bigger a little bit more round and
in a few different colors that are
obviously inspired by some close
competition so this we have here is the
silver m8 and now like i said it's more
rounded and htc likes to boast a certain
stat that the old htc one exterior was
made of 70 metal and this new one m8 is
90 metal and that's true but because of
this change i actually think the old one
fit better in the hand see the sides of
the phone were flat and sure that's you
know the polycarbonate not metal but it
gave you an edge like something to
actually grab onto while holding the
phone it was flat the new htc one rounds
this off with more metal so yes it is
now you know 90 metal versus 70 but now
there's no edge to hold on to it's just
a slippery smooth anodized aluminum all
the way around the phone
and also since this phone is a bit
larger to accommodate that bigger five
inch display bigger than last year's the
whole chassis is a bit bigger and that
makes it a little bit harder to reach
that top power button which is moved
from the left side to the right side
on the top of the device but if we're
being honest here i think the power
button is in the wrong place entirely i
think it should be on the right side of
the phone where it's easier to reach
with one hand especially for people with
smaller hands but at least it's a little
bit better than last year but one thing
that's not in the wrong place at least
to me is the headphone jack it's on the
bottom of the phone here and that is
where i like it also the whole top of
the phone is an ir blaster so you can
turn on and off your tv with an included
app
and on top of all that there is
expandable storage in this sealed phone
so there's a tray on both the right and
left side of this phone the left side is
where you put your sim card but the
right side will fit and support microsd
card up to a 128 gigs
128 gigabytes that is ridiculous and you
know what i'll drop 128 gig micro sd
card link in the description if you
don't believe me very useful for storing
movies or apps or music and stuff
offline now i am a tall person and i use
big phones because i have big hands but
still even such a tall phone because of
that back material being so slippery
it's a little bit weird to hold and i
definitely find myself using two hands
to hold it a lot of times but really
because of that power button placement
there's a lot of movement going on in
the hand and i really would have rather
had it on the side of the phone but
overall it's obvious that this is
designed to be a premium feeling phone
and i think it definitely accomplishes
that a lot of people are going to hear
the speakers and immediately think wow
that's really nice a lot of people are
going to see the display and immediately
think wow that's really nice and just
feeling this phone next to something
like a galaxy s5 or an iphone or an lg
g3 uh it's gonna feel very different in
the hand and that's very important to
people in the store when they're about
to buy it and then when they're using it
now as long as we're talking about
hardware there's a certain feature on
the back of this phone that people just
can't stop talking about and that is the
camera or the dual cameras on the back
htc got a lot of feedback last year with
the old htc ones camera that ultra pixel
camera a lot of positive but also a lot
of negative in terms of the photos that
it took and the features that you got
out of it but htc decided to go ahead
and keep that ultra pixel camera so it's
still a four megapixel sensor on the
back with that main element and then
they went ahead and added some stuff in
uh subtracted some stuff out obviously
so it's worth going in depth taking a
look at this camera so in terms of specs
here we're looking at another four
megapixel camera dubbed the ultra pixel
camera again this year a two-tone led
flash similar to the iphone 5s and a
secondary two megapixel depth sensor to
keep it simple and this sensor is used
for a couple of interesting software
effects we'll talk about the system is
called duo camera now notably missing
that we saw in the m7 is optical image
stabilization so the camera software the
interface which you can get to just by
rotating the phone sideways and tapping
that volume button is quite nice simple
very clean very intuitive and
ridiculously fast like it's very very
very fast focusing and fast taking shots
it's the closest thing i've experienced
to instant shutter on any android device
i love that
and there's some flexibility when taking
regular shots with this manual mode
which lets you manually change iso and
exposure and actually save those
settings as a custom camera if you want
so there's a lot you can do here the
software is a nice blend between
simplicity and capability like you can
really control a lot if you know what
you're doing or you can just leave it
alone and take nice shots in auto and
then there is the duo camera so after
you've taken a shot
and you open it up in the gallery you've
picked your shot and you hit that edit
button you see a couple of effects along
the bottom and these are called the duo
camera effects and these will appear
when your shot is compatible so the most
well-known one is called u-focus which
lets you tap the part of the photo you
want in focus and it'll use software
algorithms to blur the rest of the photo
and try to reproduce a natural bokeh
that you would get from a really nice
camera or some nice glass now to the
untrained eye this can look pretty nice
especially on the phone's smaller screen
but i know that they can keep working on
it and making it better since they're
updating it through the play store but a
lot of times you'll find the effect
looks pretty artificial and sometimes it
just doesn't work at all i mentioned the
photo being compatible before i found
that you have to be very careful when
you use this focus effect your photo
needs to have a very obvious subject and
a very obvious background but you'll
need to be far away enough that when you
take your photo everything is already in
focus so that it can select what's in
focus after the fact so if you do this
right
it'll make for the best eu focus effect
after the fact but if you get too close
where the background is naturally
blurred already you're never going to
get it back by clicking on it and it
looks terrible so you really have to
take an obvious foreground and
background photo to get this to work now
of course there are some other effects
uh foregrounder is pretty cool lets you
add effects to only the background to
really isolate the subject or dimension
plus which uses that extra depth
information from the second sensor to
make this trippy 3d image that responds
to the gyroscope of the phone again
really cool stuff that looks okay on the
phone but really not that great anywhere
else now when it comes to the actual
photo quality of the photos it takes
there are some really strong
characteristics of a photo from the m8
that you can see like a mile away one
really poor dynamic range it either
crushes the darks or blows out the
highlights like every time
two is a pretty nice but also pretty
dull exposure sometimes underexposed it
really doesn't like taking an image and
making it too bright but also tends to
have under saturated colors and three is
the resolution obviously it's coming in
at just four megapixels which is of
course not terrible but it means that
the front-facing selfie camera fun fact
is actually a higher resolution coming
in at five megapixels for those super
detailed instagram selfies so overall
verdict with the camera on this guy is
it's pretty good it's okay uh again
those four megapixel photos they'll look
fine on your display on your phone and
they'll look fine sending it to the web
as long as you're not viewing it uh
blowing up huge as long as you're not
printing it if you're not looking at it
on a 4k display if you're not zooming in
at all it looks fine and a lot of those
effects again will look really cool
because you can't see that it's only
four megapixels but if you're looking if
you're a photo enthusiast if you really
inspect pixel peep those photos a lot
and you do a lot of editing and share
them on more than just the web you're
going to want to check out some of the 8
12 even 16 megapixel photos on cameras
like the galaxy s3 s5 and note 3 and
others so
definitely not the best camera on the
market but it's certainly decent
mid-range i would say
and i would love to have optical image
stabilization back anyway there's a bit
to be said about the software besides
the camera software this is htc sense 6
on top of android 4.4 and i think it's
my favorite skin on top of android right
now now don't get me wrong i still love
stock android and i would still take
that any day of the week and i have a
lot to say about the google play edition
of this phone but this version of htc's
software sense 6 is the least obtrusive
yet it really feels like an adjustment
to android rather than a layer on top of
it performance is also excellent
throughout obviously since this thing is
powered by top-notch hardware top-notch
graphics opening and closing apps and
flipping through your daily user
interface super quick everything is very
very responsive and you probably expect
that and it looks kind of nice like i
said it feels like an adjustment to
stock android one nice touch i've
noticed is the notification bar color
changes depending on where you are in
the phone so if you're on the home
screen or the lock screen the
notification bar is clear but in certain
htc apps the color of the notification
bar changes to match the app so in
blinkfeed for example to the left of
your home screens it changes to green to
match and it does it quite smoothly and
all the other stock htc apps that come
with the phone have their own color and
they have that effect on the
notification bar and i guess non-htc
apps just change it to gray so yeah i'm
liking that it's a nice touch and little
things like this are sprinkled here and
there inside of sense 6 to really spice
up the design
and i do think it looks nice also htc
stepped up the display size so we're
looking at a five inch 1080p display
here now instead of 4.7 and that gives
us on-screen buttons for sense six to
work with so your software home back and
multitasking button and you can also
swipe up to get to google now like on a
nexus unfortunately they kept that chin
bar on the phone with the htc logo on it
but i've been told by a few that they
needed to keep the device this tall to
fit all the components including those
massive beautiful boom sound speakers in
fact
let's talk about the speakers let's talk
about them they are awesome they're the
best why aren't they standard actually
is my question they make every single
other phone literally every other phone
sound like crap honestly you can't get
much better of an audio experience than
a phone than this you get a much more
immersive gaming experience
i actually enjoy watching youtube videos
and listening to music on this phone the
alarm clock is ridiculously loud in the
morning which i guess is also good and
the drivers are so big and so far apart
they actually get a bit of a stereo
effect when things move across the
screen in a good movie it's brilliant i
love it so i have nothing bad to say
about the speakers other than the fact
that they are so big that they make the
phone really tall and htc has also come
up with a way to combat the phone's
tallness since the power button is kind
of hard to reach they come up with a few
ways to turn the display on without ever
touching that awkwardly placed power
button so this stuff might remind you of
lg's flagships so you can double tap the
phone when it's upright to turn the
screen on that's nifty
you can swipe down when the screen is
off and that will start voice calling
which unfortunately sucks at recognizing
voices it's not google recognition but
it's there and it works you can swipe
left to bring
your home screen up so if you're in an
app or something and you swipe left from
the off screen it'll bring you right
home again it always goes to your home
screen and same with swiping right
that'll always bring you to blinkfeed
wherever you are so again you could be
in an app or doing something uh and if
you have your screen off and you swipe
right you'll get ready to blink feed
lastly you can swipe up and just that'll
bring you to just wherever you were last
so if you were in an app or your home
screen wherever you were and you swipe
up you'll be brought right back to that
screen you left off at so with all this
knowledge in theory you'll never need to
touch the power button again
except to turn the screen off so htc is
doing some really nice stuff with sense
including pulling a motorola and making
a couple of them like the gallery and
the dot view case functionality
available in the google play store which
can be updated really quickly and for
free now all that being said i do have
the google play edition of the one m8
in-house so thumbs up if you want to see
a separate video review of that but a
lot of these features from sense six
that are moved to the play store will
also be available on the google play
edition which is why i have a lot to say
about why the google play edition is
probably going to be my most used phone
uh i'm really liking the google play
edition htc one m8 but if you're in it
for the sense features you're probably
going to want to get the traditional one
another thing i was impressed with with
this phone was the battery life now it
is a sealed back phone you can't get
into this and swap out the battery but
it's got a sealed in 2600 milliamp hour
battery it's a little bigger than the
old htc one the old hdc1 didn't have the
best battery life in the world but this
thing is great it is a power sipper uh i
would not have any problem recommending
going a whole weekend with this phone
with light use i've gotten two full days
to use out of this phone and it's
definitely a very light battery user
when you're not really using it a whole
ton and even when that 5-inch 1080p
display is on and you're gaming and
you're using it a lot it doesn't burn
through battery like some other phones
i've used so this is one of the best
batteries in the market even though it's
not a 3 000 milliamp hour battery or
3300 milliamp hours it's still great
i'll show you some of the usage stats
i've gotten out of it but typically i
can get through a full day pretty easily
with this phone i haven't been able to
wear it down in a typical 24 hour use
period so very impressive there and
something else that's even i guess like
a small thing i usually don't use auto
brightness on phones i usually manually
control the brightness because they tend
to have some weird sensitivity problems
but this is one of the first ones in a
while that i'm okay with the way it uses
auto brightness
outside turns it all the way up inside
turns it down to a comfortable level i'm
happy with the auto brightness on this
phone i usually don't even have to talk
about that so overall i gotta say this
phone has a lot of good things going for
it and i've enjoyed the hell out of
using it for the time that i have and
like i said i do have a lot to say about
the google play edition of this phone so
again that's probably going to end up
being an entire separate review video
but for now i got to say this is one of
the best phones you can buy go in a
store try it out you're probably going
to like holding it and that's going to
be a good reason to buy it by itself
because the specs are so similar to
other flagships so check it out i don't
have any reservations about this phone
even if you aren't a huge fan of the
camera it takes good enough shots that
this is probably one of the best phones
you can buy right now it's the 1m8
thanks for watching guys and i'll talk
to you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
you